I definitely feel like I am back in a
way as far as I kind of have my fire
back and I'm not so internal and sort of
fruity as I was four years ago or
whatever but that may happen again I
don't know and and I welcome whatever
comes my way because I'm an artist and
that's what I have to do
[Music]
brought for this new record I was like I
don't know if it like the color came
back and so the imaging reflects that
and the songs reflect that and even the
Wardrobe down the you know just a little
bit brighter and they also think that
that's what I kind of want my fans to
take away from this record is like
everybody had to go through something
everybody has a time where black is this
part of the journey you know what I mean
and it's okay to live in both but you
can't stay bogged down and something
that's that's sepia tone forever you
gotta find the rainbow
little bird
my strong suit as a writer I feel like
is sarcasm I think that's kind of where
I license whether it's bad or proper
you're fun I kind of built a career on
being cagey and a little snide like
those those just happened to be the
songs that were my biggest but then I
have some nuggets in there like over you
or house ability which I didn't write
but I feel like such a it's hard to
execute both when you kind of get when
you start out with a song like kerosene